yeah the Epstein doc what did you expect
it was gonna be what did you think it
was gonna be
Bill Clinton confessing you think was
gonna happen I think it's gonna be true
slain Maxwell she's on the thing like
Hello here's my story it's lighter she's
lying
I'll bet Geoffrey we were both kids like
notes you know one thing I let me tell
you what my biggest takeaway from the
Epstein documentary on Netflix lost men
Palm Beach is [ __ ] legit you don't
see money like you do in Palm Beach
let's not forget that the East Coast
invented [ __ ] money let's not forget
it there are three places on this in
this world that you see mansions like
that and there are Long Island New York
the Gold Coast along Island where the
Vanderbilt in the Guggenheim's and all
those [ __ ] live Newport Rhode
Island and Palm Beach Florida makes Bel
Air and Beverly Hills look like [ __ ]
track houses I'm talking 50 room stone
castles marble beautiful that's the
takeaway you let's be honest you do not
feel as bad for the kids when you've
seen the homes what do you want to do
work at the gap shut up
now I'm against the pedophilia in the
murder but let me tell you right now
it's a goddamn stunning estate it's a
beautiful property it's an iconic
property it's a nice place to be raped
not I am NOT for rape
but if we went down the list of places
to be sexually assaulted Palm Beach I
mean the Franklin scandal these kids are
getting sacrificed in barns and [ __ ]
it's Omaha they were eating at waffle
houses this is palm [ __ ] [ __ ]
Beach private islands ranches in New
Mexico limestone mansions right by
Central Park in New York City that's
where you took away from the
there's nothing else there is I mean you
know the entirety of the story of the
entire documentary is isn't it is is
that they divorce it from any historic
precedent of this happening before and
when the Vikki Ward is a journalist who
when I had Whitney Webb on the program
and if you watched a Whitney web show
you know that a lot of what you learned
in the Epstein doc you previously
learned on my show and more by the way
and don't get a twisted censorships not
all about not letting the information
come out this online censorship it's
about they want to triple it out and
they want to earn all the money off it
so don't kid yourself it's not only that
they don't want it to come out they want
it to come out in their [ __ ]
miniseries they want it to come out the
way they you know when they can profit
off it okay that's why when the Epstein
story happens you know people go in to
buy the rights and these these mega
Hollywood guys get the rights to these
stories because then they're controlled
how the narrative is it is told to
people and the money you know so it's
not just about we don't want the info
out a lot of it is that but then some of
its like we're gonna have to put some of
it out if not all of it but we're gonna
earn the money from it we don't want all
these independent people you know
reaching audiences and and building any
type of equity in their own operations
online we want to control the flow of
information and capital to us so the
Epstein documentary you know in the
beginning Vicki Ward who's the
journalist we don't know if we trust I
don't know Whitney's very skeptical of
her I haven't done any research into it
it does smell a little fishy she wrote
an article about Epstein for Vanity Fair
Vanity Fair supposedly refused to
publish it but Vicki says in the
beginning she's like yep see was this
gabs be like man of mystery and so
automatically immediately in the
beginning of this series you go oh this
is a superhuman guy who's very
mysterious he's old it's all he's
once in a lifetime figure he's just a
character with all these powers that we
don't know how he has any of them but
he's just this island so to speak no pun
intended unto himself which isn't true
okay Lester's mentioned briefly it's
like in a very in a very like barely
important way and les wax was kind of
portrayed as a victim this billionaire
is a victim of Jeffrey Epstein this guy
who owns Victoria's Secret in the
limited and Jake crew I believe I'm not
sure but he owns the first two he's a
billionaire the largest most expensive
residents in Ohio was a victim of
Jeffrey Epstein
he just got conned by this dictionary
salesman going door to door
Epstein just less Wexler's just happened
to give him a mansion in Manhattan and a
ranch and all this money gave them
billions of dollars he got swindled by
Jeffrey Epstein supposedly swindled by
Jeffrey Epstein a college dropout from
New York City gets swindled well all
throughout the film we have to believe
that everybody's being swindled and
tricked and hustled and nobody has any
clue as to what's going on and Epstein
gets a job at Bear Stearns and they find
out he never went to school and I've
seen talks his way back into Bear
Stearns and okay maybe maybe not we
don't know and he got this job at Dalton
his prep school in New York City and our
current Attorney General bar his father
I believe hired Jeffrey Epstein to teach
math at a prep school New York City one
of the top schools in the country Dalton
and and he got that job as a college
dropout and we're asked to believe that
all of these things and not one or two
of them but every single one is this
happenstance trickery that Jeffrey
Epstein is able to just move through all
these circles of people swindle them
take their money blackmail them
potentially we don't know but somehow
always come out of a shitstorm smelling
like you know lilies flowers he's fine
he's able to do that we're all supposed
to believe this and we don't
talk about any historical precedent for
this there's it none of it is mentioned
the Franklin scandal is not mentioned
they do not mention any thing about
Jimmy Savile who is a BBC presenter and
a heinous pedophile sick sadistic guy
and they don't go into any of this they
don't go into any of the credible
allegations about the kick or boys home
they don't go into any of it
they don't talk about the Catholic
Church it's pretty focused primarily on
Epstein is this man of mystery they
don't talk about blackmail operations
having been used before sexual blackmail
underage kids being used before no one
brings that up we're all supposed to
just believe that that Jeffrey Epstein
just exists on this cloud and he's
floating above everything and this
somehow he's able to make this
sweetheart deal which lets all of his
accomplices named or unnamed how insane
is that you're not even named just
anyone who was involved anyone that had
their dick out on that island you're
good that was the deal and we're
supposed to believe that he just you
know he's just lucked into that deal and
it's just what it is just locking
Charles Caspari know now that guys were
CNBC's the girl you'd always in the
palms it's on the Fogg good it's on the
fondue toward other people to work there
they're not that bright you know who's
not that bright you you're not that
bright Charles because we both know
that's poor [ __ ] we know you could keep
somebody alive if you want to this was
the highest profile criminal in this
country you know in a long long long
time and the idea that like there was no
way to keep him alive he's just
completely insane you had cameras and
cells you know the guards were asleep
and the cameras weren't working
anybody believing the official story at
this point was in on it if you're on
social media going I think that guy
killed himself you know whether you know
you're in on it you did it but that was
the Epstein documentary people wanted me
to comment on that
nothing to comment on truly there's
beautiful real estate if you like real
estate as I do many of you know of
listen this program I love real estate
because many of the people who've
succeeded at it seemed to be
developmentally disabled and that gives
me hope when I watch these television
shows and I see the idiots that are able
to amass fortune selling real estate I
believe that I could potentially have a
second career real estates a great
fantasy career that I could just sling
homes to people but that's all you're
gonna get out of the documentary the
women that come forward or brave there
they should be listened to
it's heart-wrenching the types of girls
that they preyed upon our girls from
broken homes that it's suffered abuse I
mean it's not it's worth a watch it's
well worth watching I'm telling you that
if it wasn't I would tell you but it's
not going to alter your perception of
the events there's no real new
information it's still worth watching
but it's not so in between you know
throwing a Molotov cocktail a boss to
mark it go and check it out if nothing
else but to see Palm Beach it's
beautiful but that's really what it
comes down to is that you're not gonna
get a real story in any documentary
you're not gonna get the real story ever
sorry you know what the real story is
you know it was a blackmail operation
people have secret lives they are
provided with illicit substances drugs
people streams of money they're provided
with these things and they are to be
controlled by people that want to
control them and one of the ways you
control people is by having damaging
potentially damaging
formation on those people and that's
what this is it's not a huge mystery um
you know when you start realizing that
President Clinton there was a governor
of Arkansas became the President of the
United States Arkansas you know at that
point I don't know what the population
of Arkansas was but you know I mean
what's the population of Arkansas now
it's like 3 million so at that point it
was probably 1 million you know what I
mean like you know probably you know one
and a half two million people and then
the guy becomes the President of the
United States of America yeah was 2.3
million in 1990 Arkansas one of the
smallest most inconsequential states in
the Union but he ends up the President
of the United States so you start
thinking about those things you know how
does that happen how does that happen
it's in an accident in an accident
probably not you know I mean it doesn't
mean that everybody's a pedophile it
just means that you know you have
leverage on people you know Obama became
the president how did that happen you
know these men were talented they were
gifted they were driven they had all of
those things I'm not suggesting that
either one of them wasn't didn't possess
superhuman abilities but somebody's got
to sign off somebody's got to sign off
somebody's got to loosen the purse
strings open up the vault and give you
all the money that's what happens
somebody's got to sign off doesn't mean
that these stars in Hollywood aren't
famous a lot of them are famous but they
got to get an opportunity somebody's got
a you know open the door you know you
got to get that opportunity and that's
the same thing as politics doesn't mean
everybody gets it from doing something
illegal or shady but that's certainly a
possibility you know and they end up in
the political realm certainly a
possibility so it's well worth a watch
go check it out but we know what the
story is and we just don't talk about it
every week you know I think some of you
were disappointed I just don't talk
about it every week it's it's boring we
know what it is let's figure something
else out you know what it is
we're against it I mean I don't want to
tell you it's like people who look world
you talk more about dual chord spoons
what do you want to say we did it we
know what it is we figured it out
I don't know day in and day out what I'm
supposed to do I don't even know why
people like you gotta overtake on the
epstein-barr I mean yeah you hear it dad
you have it I wasn't expecting from it I
didn't get anything out of it I mean
that's the take I mean guys you you you
have to start understanding there isn't
going to be a resolution here there's
not going you guys think this is a
television show with the season finale
or a series finale and the it's boom
it's big it's Breaking Bad the last
night we all huddle on the couch
nothing's gonna stop me from watching
this I'll get in five accident if I have
to and a bed that my car [ __ ] my family
doesn't matter I'm getting in front of
that TV cuz it's all common to the bill
is coming to tonight the justices sir
it's not no it's a show that goes on for
too many seasons where you go I this is
silly
yeah it's solana yeah I don't know I
can't get into any mo she's soap opera
that goes on and on and on and when you
start to look at it like that you you
just start you get away a little bit you
take a little breather I you know I
don't want to do a show every week about
the epstein and this one and then that
one I I don't want to break my brain
many of you have broken your brains you
don't even know it you think Donald
Trump's tunnelling under Central Park
rescuing kids you believe things of
which there are no evidence for I'll
tell you what he's doing where we're
inching closer and closer to a civil war
and he's pouring gasoline on that but
you guys think he's out there tunneling
and helping children and I'm so afraid
of becoming one of you I'm so afraid of
having my brain broken it's how I make a
living I earn money because I have a
brain and I can speak
eeeek and i can understand and process
things huh you know some of you I just I
get so scared of becoming you I'm like
what happens just too many trips too
many trips to read it wherever you go in
the forms too many trips and I don't
know what happens but and it's easy it's
easy to break your brain I'm not the
healthiest eater it's not like I'm doing
like five miles a day in a canyon like
Rogan like my brain could easily lose
out of my ear and I could become one of
you like a bumbling lunatic like a
babbling psychopath muttering about
nonsense thinking that we were just one
week away enjoy the show
yeah we will we will enjoy the show
[ __ ] lunatics